99 of all freshwater ice on earth is
sitting on top of greenland and
antarctica
and each year a little more of it melts
into the ocean
normally it would take hundreds to
thousands of years for it all to melt
the way
but what if something happened that
caused a massive global melt
overnight
as we slept sea levels would rise by a
whopping
66 meters coastal cities like new york
shanghai and london would drown in the
apocalyptic
mass flood forcing up to 40 percent of
the world's population
out of their homes while all this chaos
ensues above ground
something equally sinister is happening
below
all that rising salt water will
infiltrate groundwater reserves farther
inland
forcing its way into nearby freshwater
aquifers
you know the ones that supply our
drinking water
irrigation systems and power plant
cooling systems
all those aquifers would be destroyed
not
good on top of that the ice on greenland
and antarctica is made of fresh water
so when it melts that's about 69
of the world's fresh water supply that's
going straight into the oceans
this will wreak havoc on our ocean
currents and weather patterns
take the gulf stream for example it's a
strong ocean current that brings warm
air to northern europe
and relies on dense salty water from the
arctic in order to function
but a flood of fresh water would dilute
the current and could weaken or even
stop it altogether
without that warm air temperatures in
northern europe would plummet
and that could spawn a mini ice age
according to some experts
that's not even the worst of it take a
look at what will happen
when that last one percent of fresh
water ice
that's not part of greenland or
antarctica thaws
some of that one percent is sitting in
glaciers farther inland
the himalayan glaciers specifically pose
one of the largest threats
because of what's trapped inside toxic
chemicals like
dichlorodiphenyltrichloroethane
or ddt scientists discovered that
glaciers like this
can store these chemicals for decades
but as they thaw those glaciers release
the chemicals into rivers
lakes and groundwater reserves poisoning
each one as they go the rest of that one
percent is hanging out underground
mostly in the arctic tundra as something
called
permafrost permafrost is organic matter
that's been frozen in the ground for two
plus years
now one of the most immediate problems
with thawing permafrost
would be mercury poisoning that's right
there are an
estimated 15 million gallons of mercury
stored up in the arctic permafrost
that's almost equal to the amount of
mercury
everywhere else on earth on top of that
the organic matter in permafrost is a
tasty meal for microorganisms
after they digest it all they fart out
two of the most
potent greenhouse gases out there carbon
dioxide
and methane scientists estimate this
could
double the current levels of greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere
and potentially cause global
temperatures to rise by
3.5 degrees celsius compared to today
that might not sound like much but say
goodbye to that mini-european ice age
and even rivers and lakes around the
world
they'd evaporate from the higher
temperatures and cause
mass droughts and desert-like climates
and all that extra water vapor in the
atmosphere would fuel
more frequent and stronger storms floods
and hurricanes
so all of that newly established
coastline on the eastern u.s
would be one of the last places you'd
want to live
instead there would be mass migrations
to canada
alaska the arctic and even what's left
of the antarctic
and you're right this is probably never
going to happen
after all there's enough ice right now
to cover the entire continent of
north america in a sheet a mile thick
so the next time you hear about
record-breaking heat
or ultra-powerful hurricanes at least
you know
that it could be worse but scientists
estimate that if we don't take action
and global temperatures increase by just
one degree
celsius the effects of climate change we
already see today
will be irreversible so yes
it could be worse and it will be
if we're not careful